oh
oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
rocking my epic hero shop batman shirt
right now cause we're gonna watch some
new rock stars today the batman easter
eggs breakdown full movie analysis
details you missed hey leave a like
while you can if you're here you're
gonna stick around you know what to do
we watched this for the third time last
night at imax where freaking robert
pattinson showed up himself that was a
nice surprise phil and molina from new
rockstars joined us
but he missed robert pattinson he was
outside in the lobby doing push-ups or
something just can't stop working out
freak welcome back to new rock stars i'm
eric voss and this is a breakdown of the
batman matt reeves detective noir take
on the caped crusader also known as the
world's greatest detective in this case
played by robert pattinson not always
the world's greatest detective in the
story but hey it's only his second year
into it and the movie yeah the better
for it this is one of my favorite
cinematic depictions of gotham and its
broken broken toys there's so much to
appreciate about this film the clues
reeves hid throughout this film to set
up the mystery subtle details in the
camera work and the music and easter
eggs pointing to the broader dc universe
my favorite kind of movie to break down
and i'm gonna do it scene by scene
excited yeah i mean i wanted to say
really fast that we do have a ranking of
the batman movies coming up soon one
thing i did not mention is that i would
say the batman is actually the best
looking one of them all uh out of every
single one
sorry the dark knight
oh shots fired but i think i would agree
with it so the film opens with the
abrupt title text of that batman filling
the screen actually the way the 2019
joker opening title text filled that
screen but here it's kind of like one of
bruce's red tinted snapshots taken from
his eye lenses filling all of his vision
this film constantly shows extreme
close-ups of eyes and fingers objects
objects so close we can't really
distinguish them as well as the point of
view shots from those peepers a
reflection of this film's shifting
points of view that keep us guessing who
the real villains of the story are the
opening shot is actually one of these
povs from under the mask of the riddler
his breath sucking through his military
cold weather mask as he peers through
binoculars a recurring voyeurism as we
later see batman doing the same thing to
selena kyle this opening shot is
reminiscent of john carpenter's opening
point of view shots in the movie
halloween a silent boy killer heard only
by his heavy breathing from behind his
mask actually the first thing i thought
of it i think you thought of too
watching this was the movie the
conversation from francis ford coppola
which has a lot of these voyeuristic
qualities when i heard matt reeves was
saying yeah we take a lot of inspiration
from like 70s films even one at one
point conversation was dropped and that
opening popped i was like oh wow that is
so literal
i mean yeah that whole movie starts at a
telephoto lens just looking around a
square the riddler's gaze passes a cop
guard sitting at the gate didn't you see
seinfeld you never give them a chair to
sit in there's lots of holes in the
security but then he lands on the
board pretend killing his father before
heading out to trick league of shadows
so many batman films to expect the first
skin we see to be a young bruce wayne
especially since christopher nolan's
batman begins explored bruce's backstory
as a ninja but this flips a script on us
revealing it to be the son of the
corrupt mayor don mitchell jr yet still
this is a grieving boy that batman will
later feel a connection with now the
music over all this is schubert's ave
maria sung by a boy falsetto a recurring
track setting up the riddler's history
as a choirboy orphan framed in ah
that's what he's wearing uh it actually
plays later at the meredith yes yes
the orphanage and if you listen closely
throughout this film the composer
michael giacchino uses a minor key
rendition of ave maria as the writers
see music we can't pause every freaking
little detail but i'm sorry i'll stop
that attention to detail is so
impressive like everything is just so
humed as john loves to famously say so
masterfully crafted and the idea of that
music choice i remember hearing i wonder
what the choice of that was because it
does evoke a level of elegance and
prestige when looking upon this mayor's
household this dude is like super
freaking wealthy yeah it was like a
cathedral essentially yeah that's kind
of the vibe i was sort of getting but
then i did notice they would come back
throughout the film yeah and uh that's a
good personal indicator of the rhythm
now opening on halloween night is
definitely a nod to the long halloween
the first real great batman detective
storyline from the comics a story that
ties heavily into the falcons and the
moroni's other comic influences were
batman year one and cook's ego both arcs
you definitely want to read but really i
gotta say matt reeves clearly made this
movie its own thing and you could just
point to anything in this movie and say
it was from any comic book ever but this
movie is better appreciated for its
cinematic details not as just a list of
comic book easter eggs so that's the
approach i'm going to go in this
breakdown because speaking of carpenters
halloween there is a great michael
myers-esque reveal of the riddler
directly behind the mirror yeah
the tv light flickers brighter like
batman the riddler first appears to us
from the shadows but never steps out of
those shadows until he is ready to kill
not giving his prey an opportunity to
see him and make a different choice now
this riddler look with the glasses over
the mask is inspired directly from the
description of sir killer who also
taunted police and the media with
mysterious ciphers and the target own
alphabet he clubs the mayor with a
tucker a tool used in carpeting proving
the riddler planned from the beginning
for batman to find this tool and use it
later to uncover his home floorboards to
reveal his long game to bomb the city's
sea walls what a freaking bookend that
is you know what i learned recently is
that paul dano he actually like taped
his whole body getting so into character
because cling wrap yeah yeah and that he
instantly regretted it afterwards i'd
imagine how awful that is oh yeah but i
love the reasoning too like you know i
gotta have like my alter ego so i can't
shave my whole body yeah and then we
jump to halloween night from bruce's
perspective we actually start on these
weird two glowing shapes that look like
eye holes from inside his batman cowl
that's not just me
actually part of the bat signal igniting
steaming in the rain and you'll notice
this bat signal is not the clean stencil
that we have seen before but a chunk of
metal jammed into the shutters were so
grounded
batman and gordon are really in the
early days of their partnership also
reflected on the location of this bat
signal in this unfinished construction
site i actually never picked up one i
just thought it was like a good section
to have a secret bat signal to a certain
extent but now it's like the physicality
of it just goes to show we don't support
you
yeah
you gotta run down under construction
building that'll probably never open
shitty bats then we see gotham's times
square region with a gotham empire
building a holiday in gotham a bank of
gotham the gotham tribune and then this
screen psa warning addiction to drops on
the rise drops being the name of a new
eye drop drug of this world the guy who
robs the store is actually wearing a
green drop mask he's a literal drop head
and this one is called good times
grocery which is an easter egg to robert
pattinson
which matt reeves said that he watched
while writing this script for this movie
that made him want to cast robert
pattinson that's amazing it's almost
raining in gotham a detail lifted
directly from the movie seven in which
david fincher made sure it was raining
in every exterior shot in the city to
show the oppressive nature of urban life
bruce describes how the gothamites
ignore the rain all this rain setting up
the city's eventual flooding in the
third act the more water the more the
criminals are able to overtake the city
he only has half of his face painted
since he has not yet earned his full
spot in the game i did see like heavy
spoilers paul had a thumbnail that said
future robin on it
i wonder if that video if he's tying it
in paul if you happen to watch this
comment below comment below or shoot me
a text would you now after we saw two
fake outs where criminals looked into
the shadows of an alley terrified that
batman would step out of it one of my
favorite parts does here on the train
platform giakino's score evokes john
williams imperial march for darth vader
[Music]
by the way the cinematographer on this
movie was greg frazier who also dp'd
rogue one which had its own iconic darth
vader shots and he introduces himself
and he did doom too
for batman opening sketch since we had
to really remember all the moves i've
seen that moment so many times that
every time i watch this movie i'm so
distracted because i'm going the sound
effects are different
they're not the same yeah they're not he
doesn't even have that yell when his arm
cracked
and also in the trailer they cut away to
the reaction after he punches him down
but in the movie it's all one shot yeah
yeah
until he says on vengeance and then they
cut i'm vengeance yes now this is a year
two batman still getting his name out
there and he's actually called vengeance
more often than he's called batman in
this movie also i am vengeance is part
of his famous three-line phrase from the
nothing to fear episode of batman the
animated series
i am the knight
[Music]
well i think that it's also so symbolic
for him to mainly be called vengeance
because that's how people view him so
much until by the end when he's viewed
as a hero because he has to arc out of
that too batman tases the last guy on
the throat showing that batman's armor
itself must be electro proof setting up
how he survives getting shocked by that
generator in the flooded arena in the
final act batman joins lieutenant smart
crime scene showing off some impressive
detective skills deducing the thumb was
severed when the mayor was still alive
and noticing a bloody mark on the floor
from where the murder weapon bounced
over there but even the photographer was
like oh what's he looking at oh damn i
should snap a shot i love that detail it
does live up to his title of the world's
greatest detective but i would argue in
his film he's actually not yet that much
of a detective he makes some crucial
errors but it makes for a much better
story especially for someone at the
beginning of his career in vigilantism
on the walls still investigating
bust referring to the gang of sal
moroney rivals to the falcons the whole
thing we later learned in the movie a
total sham i imagine that the moroni's
in the falcon family that will all be
explored thoroughly in the gotham pd
series that was interesting we don't
ever see anything about moroni but this
movie does no flashbacks that'll single
flashback in this movie yeah
newspapers also include a subtler
headline about the city's sea wall
construction problems teasing the
riddler's final plan to target those sea
walls and then this clue from your
secret friend who having a clue
let's play a game just me and you this
card with the skeleton saying from your
secret friend was modeled directly on
the real life card sent by the zodiac to
san francisco chronicle reporter paul
avery that had a skeleton saying from
your secret pal the riddle is what does
a liar do when he's dead answer he lies
still is decodable using the same double
letter technique cited by robert
graysmith in the zodiac film that's the
most common double consonant in the
english language the double l and what's
the one word that we know that he'll use
in here at least once
you'll notice how later alfred will try
using the same technique to mark off all
the double o's before bruce realizes
that eliminating the six letters that
they were given fills out the riddler's
favorite ryan gosling movie from the
crime scene the music ships
fighting in the way with kurt cobain's
lyrics reflecting this grunge take on
batman from robert pattinson a guy who
wishes he was homeless and feels more
comfortable on the streets at night but
also as the final track on nirvana's
never mind album it actually precedes a
secret track that comes after 10 minutes
of silence called endless nameless so
this recurring track in the movie is
really the something in the way of
bruce's true mindset as he is a
detective masking a secretly violent
monster underneath that layer cobain's
lyrics also represents the animals i
trapped referring to the past criminals
that batman has caught in these first
two years and how the riddler literally
traps animals in cages for batman to
find if you told me like a couple years
ago that they'd be playing something in
the way in a batman movie i'm like i
don't know about that but it works so
earlier
what i was learning recently is that a
big part of why matt reeves wanted
robert pattinson was that while writing
him when listening to nirvana he was
reading up on kurt cobain and how kurt
cobain you know obviously wanted to be
this like great artist and make a
difference the last thing he wanted was
any fame that made him think of like
robert pattinson who like wants to be a
great actor but doesn't really want to
deal with the fame side of things when
he started applying that to bruce wayne
and why for this one going down the more
reclusive route with bruce wayne he went
hey he's kind of like kurt cobain kind
of like rubber paddington wants to be
batman do the work but he doesn't want
any of the public spotlight on it right
as bruce arrives in his bat cave the old
wayne tower subway station wayne
terminus we hear cobain singing
underneath the bridge tarp has sprung a
leak another indication that the flood
is coming a flood that probably will
actually flood this whole back
i love that there's another line about
like the animals becoming his friends
bruce's moody voiceover has actually
been his journal entry in a notebook
labeled gotham project framing this
batman as a young physician
experimenting with different cures for
the city a doctor
that's a good interpretation who
approaches the ills of the city as a
forensic accountant looking for and
diagnosing redundancies where the
numbers don't add up but not prescribing
true cures to those discrepancies his
first entry in this film is the night of
thursday october 31st and in the
epilogue after the flood it's the
morning of wednesday november 6th
meaning the whole movie transpires in
about six to seven days but it is the
dawn of the seventh day in genesis it
took god seven days to create the
universe but since we are right on the
border between that sixth and seventh
day the sixth day is when god created
man we haven't fully gone through that
seventh day yet a way of showing how in
this movie we have not yet fully
acquired that seventh day of rest
there's still work to be done when bruce
joyce
i love that the morning sunlight he has
to put on sunglasses as he is a
self-described nocturnal animal who's
getting too accustomed to seeing
nighttime prey through his special
lenses kind of like morphe's line in the
matrix his eyes hurt because he's never
really used them it's so funny here on
the ground floor there's actually a bust
of william shakespeare which could be a
possible nod the 60s adam west batman
the batcave was accessed by a button
hidden in shakespeare's bust then in the
mayor's garage batman knows which car to
check from the shears and the tire left
there by the riddler the shears probably
used to sever the mayor's thumb which is
why batman then looks for a usb thumb
drive port thumb drive and they say this
movie doesn't have jokes batman
that was really fun it was the
moonlighting cop named bill kenzie who's
actually a narco from the gotham central
comics and batman means oz cobblebot the
penguin there's a great visual exchange
here where he sees selena kyle boots
first and then as selena exchanges cash
for drops with oz selena quickly
recognizes anika from the photos which
batman notices and then later after
talking to oz he sees the same boots on
annika in the photo so knows for sure
that the two must be involved somehow
but then my favorite detail in this
movie comes right after this as they
exit the lounge we're outside in the
upper corner of the frame there's a lit
window showing a silhouette snapping
photos of the lounge entrance this is
the real life oh
[ __ ]
30 minutes the box folks but this isn't
revealed and confirmed until two hours
later that nashton's home is across the
street from the lounge and you'll notice
this is in a hotel lit in a green neon
sign that was worth it for the video
alone
holy crap oh wow great detail oh man
detail if that's confirmed i hope matt
reeves watches this video eric
oh that is brilliant that is like a
comic book man next time i watch it i'm
really looking out for specifically that
this is under our noses from the
beginning of the film i love it then
after sparring with selena batman finds
her overdue electric bills that list
selena's address as queen street and
gotham us there's no state listed
because throughout the comics of the
films gotham's exact location in the
united states tends to shift around the
news reports commissioner savage's
murder his head in a cage fed to
snarling rats a detail from george
orwell's 1984 when winston is tortured
in room 101 with his head in a similar
rat cage then when examining his body
batman and gordon look at the riddler's
rat maze with the new cipher in a linear
path in a tray is a second riddle this
time a purple envelope with a card
showing a mad scientist pouring
chemicals i'm mad about you want to know
my name just look inside and see and
then inside an explosion with but wait i
cannot tell you that might spoil the
chemistry of course teasing the regular
rigging up a bomb for the ta and at the
bottom he writes follow the maze till
you find the rat bring him into the
light you'll find where i'm at batman
then teams up with salinas that she
wears his recording lenses to scan vips
in the club here she meets d.a gil
coulson and as she talks with them her
red wig contrasts with the blue light on
his face which gets colors to get
mirrored at the end of the night when
the riddler straps the neck bomb to him
in the car which reeves and frazier keep
way out of focus just flashing blue and
red lights evoking a police squad car
ironic for him being the arm of the law
but now facing justice for his own
corruption i also really like the detail
of coulson having to wipe the steam off
the windshield since riddler had been
sitting in this parked car all night
steaming it up and as the camera pulls
back from this attack it's all framed
with a gotham sea wall in the foreground
the waves right up to the top super high
tide from all this rain marking this
street corner as one of the targets of
the riddler's later detonations
you know what i love so much about this
movie it gave me a performance from an
actor who i generally just don't like
for some irrational reason
years and like i do not like this actor
and then in this movie i was like he's
really good one of the first things we
touched our car my first greeting is
peter starsgard that's what he's doing
man he's great alfred has translated the
maze cipher two you are el rata a lotta
saying that the spanish isn't perfect
since as oz later points out rata alada
is a spanish feminine noun an adjective
meaning it should have the pronoun of la
not l a clue of course setting up the
word play of u r l also perhaps a nod to
the spelling of grammatical mistakes
throughout the zodiac's letters and
ciphers which some code breakers believe
may have actually been intentional
probably not but most of these criminals
think they're smarter than they are
alfred gives bruce thomas's family cuff
links a w with a curved line through it
which visually matches the designs that
the riddler used for many of his symbols
hard lines with curved s-shapes or
question mark shapes snaking through
them at the mayor's funeral bruce gets
met with paparazzi now later in the
riddler's home there's a newspaper
clipping wall of a pass bruce wayne
tabloid photo with a smiling face behind
him that matches the smile of barry
killen who plays the joker
still in one of the final scenes now i
didn't see barry keown in this mom but i
just love the idea that he might have
stalked bruce as one of these
photographers in the past similar to how
john doe in seven cameoed in plain sight
earlier in the film as a paparazzo you
know what i love about that wall it's a
room full of cops
that man's looking upon it the wall is
clearly saying hey riddler's figured out
that bruce wayne and batman are one in
the city
or no one bothers to go what's he trying
to i think with all of this connecting
with those jaw lines really quick what's
going on who's batman's got photos
i know who you really are before jeffrey
richards tournament are you bruce wayne
that's where you get all your money
resources from inside a young man tries
to sneak past a barrier before getting
caught in bruce chats with another angry
father glad that the mayor's dead both
of these men are wearing dull green and
jackets i think they were both among
riddler's followers who later attacked
the rally that angry dad is definitely
the same guy who later gets unmasked on
the catwalk and says he's oh [ __ ] his
funeral gets interrupted
that's a neat detail
i thought it was a different actor
i love how for all this we stay inside
the church we only hear the faint [ __ ]
revs the screams the dull pops the
gunshots all growing louder and louder
until the suv crashes in you'll notice
the riddler painted the letters d-o-a on
the car a joke for the d.a being d-o-a
dead on arrival and using a neck bomb
this way may be inspired by the horrible
incident involving brian wells in 2003
very complex plot that involved theft
and blackmail i'd recommend a
documentary talking about that but i
hate that documentary because it showed
the death with zero trigger warning
netflix could you please just put a
little trigger warning before that part
happened i saw it
yeah to claim his third riddle now in a
yellow envelope in these trying times
never forget i'm just a phone call away
and then he wrote ring ring ring dozens
of times you'll notice the text gets
more and more crammed in toward the
bottom of the card the riddler's live
stream includes comments egging the
riddler on including one that says hope
it's a dud and we gotta do it all again
tuesday a clue for how the riddler
actually plans to blow up the sea wall
on tuesday
oh my god what a detail what a detail
give me the details
oh [ __ ] and i'm always trying to read
that stuff and usually i've never seen
that before i'm like oh what a great
clue well his followers are the ones
involved in the action at the end in
madison square not madison square garden
gotham square
gotham garden square garden square park
i'm not sure i don't know we're a bunch
of idiots enough we're fake fans others
diss batman screw the poser in black i
need more riddler and what if that's
body armor i think it'll stick him from
the blast indeed it totally does the
riddler asks it can be cruel poetic or
blind but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice second riddle if
you
are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind mind
he's referring to the cost of closing
the take is different too ten thousand a
month not to prosecute certain cases
which brings us to the third riddle
since your justice is so select please
tell us which bourbon you're paid to
protect but because coulson will not
give up the
the rats clashes with the gcpd but
gordon helps him escape with a dramatic
leap off the tower and wingsuit glide
but the part of the l train that he
closed lines is actually right next to
that neon green hotel sign so this is
right where the riddler lives he
probably saw this guy
suspecting the penguin is the winged
dragon they follow into a drug deal at
the recycling plant leading to this
shootout and chase this movie's
batmobile fires up it's a true muscle
car with an exposed engine flames
bursting off the side of the
undercarriage like batman himself he's
ready to explode this street chase is
some of the best action filmmaking i
have seen reeves and frazier mount the
cameras on the sides of the car it's
such a good choice looking through the
side view mirror or we're in the back
seat looking out meanwhile the music
that jaquino uses here interrupts his
main batman theme with rapid percussive
breaks
so that we only hear the charging theme
when the batmobile gains on the penguin
also they the the
into barrels which syncs perfectly with
the percussion they pass under some
highway signs with dc references the
gotham docks are free docks used by
organized crime in the games robinson
park is a poor neighborhood in gotham
city where selena kyle lived during the
no man's land storyline try corner yards
versus a tri corner it's a
triangle-shaped island on the south side
of gotham where the gcpd is located in
no man's land and then hinckley river
could refer to south hinckley a downtown
borough in the gotham knight anthology
film and a location in dark knight rises
yeah maybe it reaches its finest
as batman approaches oz we see him
framed upside down in the fire upside
down like a bat hanging from a boat yeah
and i love this after they interrogate
the penguin he waddles after them with
the angles bound moving just like a
penguin does doesn't uh colin farrell
kind of remind you of like robert de
niro oh nancy yeah what are you showing
me come on
yeah he's got that like facial rubbery
untouchables vibe to him too that's
where he's gonna be ascending to but the
riddler lures them back into the
orphanage that thomas wayne donated to
the city but since his renewal fund was
emptied it fell to ruin a projector
shows thomas's mayoral campaign
announcement beside a group of choir
boys one of whom was edward nashton and
i like how when bruce realizes he is the
next target the riddler's previous two
riddles come back to haunt him the woman
picking up the phone and the old man
blowing up alfred
dory
to tell him he was too late as bruce
tries to figure out that is gnarly
excellent catch
an overhead shot positions him at the
center of all this evidence as his dual
rules as both the wayne heir and batman
make him really the center of the
riddler's plot more center than even the
riddler realizes selena reveals falcone
is her father as has been the case in
the comics and bruce sees the riddler's
latest video detailing the histories of
the wayne and the arkham families how
reporter edward elliott uncovered the
secret of martha's parents this is a
hush reference leading to her being in
and out of arkham for years she was
actually the heiress of the arkham
family riddler wrote over this the word
hush referring to thomas's hush payments
on this story but also a clear nod to
the batman hush storyline another great
detective mystery that also features
batman and catwoman romantically
involved while the riddler orchestrates
this plot from behind bars that
reporter's name being edward elliott
could be announced to the great
grandfather of thomas elliott aka hush
in that storyline thomas's cease and
desist comes from the law firm of miller
and moore an easter egg to the comic
writers frank miller and alan moore who
wrote what i think so cool
so cool perspective gosh
bruce you're wondering
had his parents killed to keep thomas
from being a forever loyal asset to
falcone but alfred clarifies that thomas
was actually planning to sell out
falcone to the police on the night that
they were murdered he could just never
verify if it was actually falcon's doom
and i love love love probably keeps it a
mystery selena is able to get the truth
out of kinsey that falcone killed annika
and that falcone was the true winged rat
being protected by city leaders and
ruling over the corruption of all of
gotham as everyone was really draining
thomas's billion dollar renewal fund the
way this mystery unfolds in the movie
parallels the movie chinatown which
explores how the city of los angeles was
built on corrupt dealings around the
city's water infrastructure including
the twist of the top boss having a
secret daughter batman champion
falcone with an amazing hallway shot
from reeves and fraser lit only by the
flashing of the machine guns just like
frasier's hallway shot in rogue one lit
only by the lightsaber in the blasters
and let's not forget mavericks did a
similar type of shot in war for the
planet of the apes already
mother falcone gets arrested and he
taunts gordon saying what are you with
zorro here classically it was outside a
screening of a zorro film where bruce's
parents were killed in the comics which
is one of his inspirations to don a
black mask but the riddler shoots
falcone dead and batman notices this is
under a flickering street lamp bringing
the rat into the light also marking the
spot as one of those blinking christmas
lights in the riddler's floor mat right
next to where a sea wall bomb was
planted the riddler surrenders calmly in
a diner with imagery actually matching
edward hopper's painting nighthawks but
his surrender at the end of the film's
second act plus the police's discovery
of his horror show apartment is also
directly from fincher's center yeah
and john doe surrendering to police as
part of his master plan such as the case
for the riddler who calmly traces a
question mark in his drink the riddler
has two ids one for edward nashton the
other for patrick parker both are known
aliases of edward nigma in the comics
the police are able to id nashton as a
forensic accountant that's how he knew
which city leaders were profiting from
the renewal fund and whether coulson was
telling the truth about his ten thousand
dollar bribes and why here all of his
journals are written on ledgers you'll
notice a close-up of one of the pages
shows entries from july reading i know
what i must become a line that he
repeats then over and over and over
below like a student repeating a lesson
as a punch man on a chalkboard what he
must become is a masked vigilante
something he learned from batman whom he
viewed as a silent partner someone he
thought would be impressed with his work
batman finds one more letter in a red
envelope in a bat cage a card with a
proverbial monkey dancing for an organ
grinder this proves that the riddler at
least at first did not know bruce wayne
and batman were the same person if his
plan was to kill bruce with the bomb
that alfred opened and then for batman
to find the see you in hell note
followed by this card riddler must have
thought he could kill bruce wayne and
then celebrate afterwards with batman a
separate person but the way the riddler
whispers his name here
way
does make it seem for a beat that the
riddler is saying it to batman to taunt
him but then the scene backpedals when
the rhythm comes back to insane bruce
wayne he's the only one we didn't get
which i think is a great twist showing
how the riddler saw him and batman
working together to bring down the
elites like bruce wayne and he was just
repeating the name out of his own
personal lingering envy for the orphan
who got spotlight instead of him but i
think there is another way to read this
that perhaps after setting this plan
into motion putting those stamps on all
the letters and sending them out when
bruce wayne ended up not dying in the
explosion the riddler might have been
able to conclude that that was because
he led him that night to the orphanage
accidentally keeping his target away
from harm so that maybe now you might
know that they are the same person he's
just not yet revealing that he knows
continuing to tease batman see i'm not
sure i like that i kept it a little bit
ambiguous because in that moment when
he's going bruce wayne batman's looking
down like i've been caught i'm about to
be exposed there's a camera right there
and then riddler says that line about
like the one we didn't catch but the
fact that riddler still lives and this
is only the first one in this franchise
joker's right next door to him yeah
makes me wonder if ridler knows who he
is and riddler could easily just tell
like joker that they could stop the
robes yeah yeah
which they still can it just it seems
like it'd be so early on to do that i
don't know i could make an argument
either way and the fact that paul dano
walks the line so carefully so that
we're not really sure how much the
riddler knows is what makes him so great
when batman returns to the riddler's
apartment on his social media account he
finds comments from others including one
who says don't forget the cling wrap
actually revealed an interview that
originally he committed to wrapping his
whole body in cling wrap so that the
riddler wouldn't leave any dna at the
crime scene so paul dano eventually just
gave up doing that because uh when you
wrap your body in cling wrap your skin
cannot perspire so the plan comes to
fruition in the vans explode the sea
wall caves flooding the city enacting an
old testament disaster a plague upon the
city wiping its clean and this herds
everyone in the high ground at bella
royale's campaign rally in the arena
where the riddler's followers plan to
open fire but batman drops in takes them
all down fighting alongside selena at
one point he checks himself with
adrenaline he goes full ralphie parker
so batman swings over and using the
detachable chest emblem blade that we
saw used before he cuts the cable
knowing that his shock absorbent armor
will protect him this whole thing about
the third act feeling like it came out
of nowhere a lot of people out here have
been saying every time i watch this
movie i'm usually the guy to agree with
an assessment like that no it's not even
crossed my mind because this whole time
riddler's been uprooting the corruption
the streets are dirty that always read
as like an old testament type of purging
that he's doing clean up the streets
culminating too in an election where
we're about to do this dance all over
again with new officials like it all
feels very motivated yeah so to me it
made sense i don't feel like it came out
of nowhere and i do wish at one point
batman through the baton rouge
how do you get it back after that
you brought it back in like a girl swim
down there and get the fancy knife
i mean i love this reveal as it confirms
my theory from over two years ago when i
demonstrated how that chess piece could
actually be made into a blade by fully
making one out of cardboard and then
stabbing phillip with it and then he
leads the survivors to safety he has
transformed from a shadow to be feared
to a beacon of hope and for the first
time in this movie as he looks into the
daylight he does not squint meanwhile
his voiceover describes how the flooded
city is now at risk for a new criminal
takeover as we see the penguin gaze out
at its new empire a flooded city perfect
for a penguin a flightless bird but an
excellent swimmer back in arkham barry
killing cameos as the unscreened arkham
prisoner in the cell beside riddlers
saying one day you're up the next you're
a clown laugh you maniacally while
teasing a wide grin a bit of a
disfigured face yes the joker which was
further confirmed by this movie's
post-credit clue directed us back to
rataalada.com where a new cipher
revealed the symbol for the letter z
leaving the only letter left in the
riddler's alphabet still a mystery the
letter j well mr j his new best friend
actually since then a new cipher dropped
on the site translating to you think i'm
finished but perhaps you don't know the
full truth every ending is a new
beginning something is coming still in
all those letters no jay matt reeves
actually confirmed in an interview that
there is a deleted scene in which batman
after seeing the riddler's clues
pointing to him in particular did
actually meet with the joker face to
face in arkham to consult with him i
guess kind of like chloe starling
consulting with hannibal lecter and he
indicated that it might show up on the
blu-ray release oh that was so cool do
it i feel like that weirdly would have
worked better in the movie to have that
versus what felt like kind of an
unnecessary setup for a sequel or post
or what could have been like that maybe
that should have been your post credit
scene
because if they had that scene before
that wouldn't have felt like oh look
we're teasing this yeah yeah or if you
had had the initial meeting at least
that scene would have felt more
motivated at the end exactly exactly
yeah and the final scene selena says she
is planning on moving to bloodhaven a
neighboring city in the comics known as
the base of operations of nightwing but
batman does not follow her and she says
who am i kidding you're already spoken
for now yes this is something alfred
says in the year zero comics but aselina
says that her eyes dart to the left her
eye line is connecting with the bat
signal in the sky that was the first
image we saw associated with batman in
the very opening minutes of the movie
while this movie at times flirted with
being a bat in the cat story i think its
strongest partnership was really between
batman and gordon yes yes yes
in this movie the world's greatest
detectives honestly they screwed up
constantly their spanish was bad the
only way they caught the riddler was
because he surrendered to them the city
sea wall still imploded cities left
flooded you could argue that they
completely failed their riddler
investigation really the victory belongs
to the riddler here the most corrupt
leaders of gotham are now out of the
picture but that makes batman's victory
in this movie a personal one he started
the movie blind now we can see by losing
the battle of this movie it sets him up
to win the longer war and it shows us
that work always needs to be done while
this may be the dawn of the seventh day
it is not the time for rest i obviously
love this movie and i love it more and
more each time i watch it the more i
talk about it hopefully diving into the
details helping you appreciate it more
too hey a reminder that you can get this
limited edition gotham noir shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea vos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching batman
call dibs on that shirt
unless you already have it
you already get it
it's all good buddy
all right guys well new rock stars thank
you so much for putting this bad boy
together thanks for watching us keep a
lookout for whatever batman extra
coverage we do we'll see you guys soon
[Music]
you